I mean I must say I'm nervous about it
and I hope it's not I know having read
the statement has been made I hope it's
not the Prime Minister trying to recoup
from the fact that actually I felt we've
been slightly disengaged from this
crisis although he says we're in lots of
little rooms talking to them to find
that that Angela Merkel and President
Hollande were talking with Putin and yet
David Cameron wasn't i was i was quite
surprised and shocked you know and i
hope he's not he wants Britain to be the
strongest probably attempt exactly when
that's my point i hope now he's not
something gosh that wasn't very clever
of me now I'm going to show how roughy
tough I am by putting people on you no
one has to be very careful with advisers
I don't know you're much too young but I
can remember with Vietnam there were
advisors there and these things have a
way of creeping up on you I think we've
handled the crisis badly from the
beginning there's no doubt that Putin
has behaved appallingly he's revisionist
he's an ex the first bit of European
territory that's happened since 1945
there'll be some terrible things
happening in eastern Ukraine that is all
absolutely certain but I think we've got
to be very careful the Russians have a
strange perception of NATO they think
it's an aggressive alliance they think
this is that the NATO wanted to take
over Ukraine the ordinary Russian people
think that we need to think like the
Russians and I i I'm I must say I still
remain slightly nervous we've got to be
hard line we put in place all these
sanctions although of course Putin says
the sanctions of what is causing all the
problems in Russia it's not it's oil
prices but Putin could pretend it's the
west and the Russians rally behind it
tell us a little bit more about why you
say it makes you nervous what kind of
reaction do you think it could provoke
from present people I think he will see
this as NATO starting to station troops
in the Ukraine I think that's how he
will explain it to his people now we
know they're just going there to train
on what you call non-lethal I'm couldn't
quite careful about what's non-lethal
you have very good intelligence and you
teach people to fight as infantry that
very rapidly stops being non-lethal and
I'm sure the next step would be well
let's give them some lethal weapons as
well as long lethal weapons and i am not
sure that this is quite the right way to
go at the moment what we do have to be
absolutely clear on is that the Ukraine
is different from the Baltic States or
NATO country and without a doubt Putin
has to be must be a no doubt whatsoever
that if he touches a NATO nation this
means you could L dwell end up with hot
war hot fighting I'm not sure that that
NATO EU and Britain see that they would
be involved in a hot war in Ukraine and
as Cameron said himself there's no
military solution to this I think we've
got to think out of the box and try and
tackle this in a very different way but
with all of our efforts so away from the
symbolism of this move and how that
could be interpreted by Putin what
difference do you think it will make on
the ground to Ukraine these are 75
members of the military away from the
fighting aren't they on a short-term
arrangement will they help Ukraine oh I
think I think they will be of some use
to you cray and I mean teach them use
intelligence better teach infantry
tactics teach them about logistics these
are all useful things but it's a it's a
tiny it's a tiny thing I mean they they
obviously the Ukraine will think great
this is just the thin end of the wedge
you know you will get more and more and
that's where of course the danger I
think lies but I hope it isn't just the
prime minister thinking I'm now even
sure I'm tough because I wasn't involved
in these negotiations and I do think
we've been slow about it I mean we were
signatories of the Budapest agreement
that let the Ukrainians give away their
nuclear weapons to Russia on the basis
the countries that signed it would
ensure that its boundaries were always
there the Russians were another
signatory and we haven't really grabbed
that and taken that so what should
Britain do if you're if you're worried
about this there but what should us that
our strategy being well as I said I
think we need to stick with these
sanctions I think we need to redouble
our efforts in terms of what one might
loosely call propaganda stating what the
position is I think we should call
another another sort of meeting and with
the Russians maybe as the key people in
it because they have valid interests in
that area but then maybe looking at the
whole place and saying could we set this
up on a different base could they could
the Crimea which is being annexed could
we look at this as some sort of separate
Enclave looked at maybe in the way that
Austria was looked at after the Second
World War something like that I mean we
need to have any quite radical in those
sorts of ways fully including the
Russians to make the Russians realize
NATO doesn't want to go to take over
Ukraine NATO doesn't
have troops in the Ukraine not till you
can't say this to his people but be
absolutely clear what he's done is wrong
as I say it's a revisionist action and
to be absolutely clear he must not touch
NATO and the other thing I would say
about the statement by the prime
minister he talks at the end about the
Royal Air Force things like that he is
not spending enough on defense and I
don't believe defense is being debated
enough in the run-up to the election I
actually believe that both parties have
almost got an agreement let's not talk
about it because it's too tricky that is
very silly we have not spent enough on
defense our forces have been severely
damaged by these cuts and we need to
think very hard about that in what is a
very very dangerous world okay Lord West
thanks very much indeed